[Musique]
le travail c'est de rencontrer les chefs
d'entreprise d'être à leur écoute pour
tirer parti et illustrer notre travail
parlementaire c'est que un échange se
noue entre les entrepreneurs eux-mêmes
qui
permet de faire ressortir un certain
nombre de sujets communs
notre plus grande concurrence
aujourd'hui ce sont nos propres clients
les marchés sont énormes notre part de
travail dans les marchés ils mettent
tous ne représente peut-être plus que 1
5% du volume du marché donc nos clients
finalement qu'est-ce qu'ils font masser
qui ramassent tout ils raflent tout
c'est un peu comme le chalutier qui est
un peu le fond et puis quand il sait
quand il s'est rendu compte qu'il reste
à faire ils nous appellent une retraite
c'est pour ça qu'on est on est descendu
d'un cran on s'est appauvrie on ne prend
plus le marché on est en sous traitant
sur les sous la gouttière
maintenant il ya tout le matos ici tout
ce qu'il faut
j'ai pu vérifier quel garage
l'orne est un département rural dit
rural avec un nombre d'habitants faible
285 mille habitants par contre c'est un
département où il ya beaucoup
d'industries pour par rapport au nombre
d'habitants
alors oui les fidèles de but
on a fait deux trois ans il n'a pas tout
faux missile ou un peu plus pour que
vous pouviez alors dire c'est que quand
vous allez l'utiliser dans des lieux
professionnels il n'ya pas
d'infiltration ya pas de bactéries et
que si on vient de contrôle et vous
pourrez le présenter y aura patrice x le
foie ménages chinois cela procure à 6
non plus quand vous leur tournée les
jours un peu des choses qui coulait que
de dire cela pour des pasteliers un
petit contrôle donc toujours garantir la
sécurité toute la partie alimentarité
car
on a vu dans l'une des entreprises des
personnes qui ont la capacité
d'intervenir sur trois quatre cinq
postes de travail différent il faut de
l'agilité de la formation et donc il ya
une certaine exigence aussi une certaine
discipline dans laquelle chacun doit
s'astreindre pour être à la hauteur
[Musique]
ici il ya 370 personnes
la typologie les emplois totalement open
roddick a donc c'est aussi voilà on va
monter en compétence des sauts
technologiques et des sauts de
compétences mais mais en europe et c'est
pour les personnes très éloignées
pendant qu'on apporte des produits qui
sont moins normes et à nos entreprises
on leur impose les normes
supplémentaires et qu'ils vont perdre de
la compétitivité donc ça c'est un
premier sujet le deuxième on était tout
de suite sur un peu de production
aujourd'hui on a commencé à avoir leurs
produits pour la tva les impôts voilà
déjà rentable
et le troisième de 3e le sujet ce sont
les charges sociales qui sont
relativement importantes et qui viennent
doubler le salaire net d'un salarié et
qui aujourd'hui pose des problèmes au
niveau du coût de la main d'oeuvre et
donc
des problèmes de compétitivité avec les
autres pays extérieurs notamment des
pays des sushis